could the Orville be saved as Disney
Force Hulu to continue with the
series welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi
TV and move your
[Music]
Channel Disney does own a big portion of
the Hulu streaming service and they are
about to buy the rest they are about to
spend over8 billion dollar to actually
purchase the remaining shares and the
remaining portion of Hulu and pull that
service within they are going to be
offering Hulu as part of the Disney plus
package with ESPN at a discounted rate
if you want all three services in one
over here in the UK in fact actually
Hulu shows pretty much already appear on
Disney plus you don't really know the
difference it just says Hulu at the
start for example the movie prey a
brilliant movie produced by Hulu
actually just appeared on Disney plus as
if it was a Disney plus film so I don't
think this very expensive acquisition is
actually going to make any difference to
me but it will to you lovely Americans
as Hulu is one of those platforms that
has actually increased its value over
the last few years it's got over 52
million subscribers in the US and that
hasn't really decreased during this big
credit crunch people seem to like the
platform so how does this finalized
acquisition finally actually help us
with the Orville well we've been waiting
desperately for one more series of the
Orville ever since New Horizons now I
was able to tell you a while ago that
that Hulu were discussing this with Seth
mcfallen and his production company but
they wanted to basically produce the
fourth series with a much lower budget
they spent a lot of money on New
Horizons and even though it was
successful and it was popular it was not
as popular as they were hoping it didn't
quite reach the heights they were hoping
for it just did okay so they basically
were discussing it and saying that let's
do it but let's do it at a more
reasonable budget now I don't think Seth
mcf had any problem at all with that
suggestion and they were moving forwards
I've also though been able to tell you
that actually Seth McFarland is very
busy with other projects like the Ted TV
series and that if the Orville does
return Seth McFarland was talking about
having a much smaller part in it that he
was really going to step back quite a
lot from the series now this is when
Hulu started to have its reserv ations
and I was told that several months ago
now while the strikes were on Hulu did
inform Seth mcf Fallin and his
production company that they were not
going to be picking up a fourth season
of the a don't forget that if you're
enjoying the video and you want to help
support the channel we need you a thumbs
up on the video and we need you to throw
a comment on it really helps with those
tricky little YouTube algorithms now
they agreed not to publicly announce
this basically because they were just
going to try to find another home for
the show and those conversations have
been continuing now at the moment Disney
and Hulu do have the rights to this
series so if they decided to pick up
those rights they would get a fourth
season of the Orville but why do I say
Disney May Force Hulu to produce this
series well from what I'm being told by
a very trusted source that works over
quite closely with Disney there are
people and high up Executives at Disney
that would love to see the Orville
return they were very much involved with
getting the show up and running in the
first place those people though are at
Disney not Hulu and while Hulu is still
at least partly owned by Comcast those
people over at Disney that want the
fourth season do not have the authority
to instruct Hulu to do a damn thing Hulu
was saying we don't fancy it and the
people Disney that support it really had
their hands tied and for the last six
months or so it was not 100% certain
that this sale Disney basically buying
the rest of Comcast share in Hulu was
actually going to go ahead there were
some disagreements about the overall
value of Hulu to explain this really
quickly this deal actually between
Disney and Comcast to buy the remaining
stake of Hulu was based on evaluation of
Hulu nearly two years ago that valuation
was um of well over $50
billion Comcast said that that is a
contract and they told Disney that's the
price you've already agreed the price
you need to pay it however Disney
questioned its value they said since the
credit Crunch and since now the strikes
its value has decreased and they wanted
to pay a smaller amount for the
remaining shares Comcast said no and
well there's basically been six months
of discussions we'll call it discussions
because that sounds plighter than
damnright arguments but Disney failed in
that argument the contract that they'
agreed was legally binding and they are
going to pay over 8 billion for the
remaining share the Comcast currently
own this also though means that the
people that want the Orville will all of
a sudden be in a position to instruct
Hulu to make it and that does mean that
maybe early in 2024 we will get an
announcement on a fourth season of the
Orville now this is a massive turnaround
and actually something that's a bit
strange recently we're going to have to
thank Disney for doing something we
want that's going to be a little strange
and a little bit difficult for some of
you so we may get a fourth season of the
Orville after all maybe with Captain
Grayson in charge rather than Captain
Mercer and maybe with a slightly smaller
budget let's see if once this sale goes
through Disney actually do pull the
trigger and Hulu are going to be
producing a new series of the oille but
guys get into the comments tell me what
you think is this a show that must
return even if Seth McFarland isn't as
involved as he once was and even if we
do get a slightly smaller budget or
actually did season 3 New Horizons end
beautifully and you know maybe we don't
need any more of the orille and maybe we
don't need Disney forcing Hulu to make
something it doesn't really want to make
I'd love to know exactly what you think
so please get into the comments if you
are new to the Channel please like
subscribe hit that Bell notification it
really helps us out you'll never miss
any of our new videos also you can go to
patreon.com Sidetrack which is where
most of our videos Premiere first and
you get to see them without the adverts
for a small contribution each month that
really supports the channel also you can
go to
c.co which is our dedicated website
where we do articles based on a lot of
our videos and we try to add a little
bit more information for you to digest
go and check it out as always please
stay safe and I'll see you next
[Music]
time